well I call the book is called New
Covenant because I I feel that we need
to have this covenant around water and
the Covenant that i'm talking about it
would have three parts first is a
covenant from humans and that's through
our governments to some extent and
through the United Nations and whatever
with the earth to stop destroying water
and that's probably the most important
thing we can do we have to stop
polluting surface water and it has to be
considered a crime to pollute and we
have to remember the words of Martin
Luther King who said legislation may not
change the heart but it will restrain
the Heartless and for those who will not
voluntarily stop destroying water we
have to we have to force them to to do
that we have to stop over pumping
groundwater we're not it's not
sustainable there are 23 million bore
wells in India alone going 24seven just
taking that water up its water mining
we're not allowing it's not the
sustainable use of that water its water
mining that's got to stop we have to
retain water and bring back water into
watersheds and we have to see ourselves
more as a species that needs to live
within nature's rules that try to bend
nature to our rules with our technology
and so on so that's the first and that
means more sustainable agriculture that
means that we're not going to be able to
grow you know quantities in the desert
the way we're doing now we're just going
to have to change our way of life much
more local buying local sourcing and so
on the second part of the Covenant would
be a covenant to equality in justice
around water which would be to
understand the roots of poverty in the
global south and in the global north and
to really address it so that water is a
neck is equitably distributed we call it
water for all we believe deeply that
everyone has that right and finally
we're talking about a kind of come
covenant with democracy that we feel
that this should be publicly over seen
that the water everything about it
should be public in terms of oversight
public accountability we have a right to
know
got a hold of our water and believe me
there's nothing more fundamental in a
community than some great big
corporation from another country coming
in and saying thanks very much thanks
for taking care of that water it's ours
now believe me it doesn't matter whether
your left or right or you live in the
global North or the global South or
something that just gets your just puts
it be under your bonnet about that
notion and people get up and say excuse
me I mean in Stockton California we
there was a coalition of
environmentalists and community
activists and and right-wing
evangelicals I mean it was just
wonderful it was a real coalition of
people the evangelical said that's God's
gift to us you can't take it make it a
for-profit thing no matter what the
reasons for coming together it was a
wonderful coalition that came together
to say get out that's our water so it's
it's been really interesting politically
to watch what this issue does and and
when we demand this this democratic
accountability people really respond to
it and and we're working at the United
Nations toward a a basic covenant or a
convention that says water is a human
right because in the original universal
declaration of human rights or 1948
water was not included because whoever
knew then that you could even conceive
of a time when water would be disputed
like this I mean it just wasn't in
people's consciousness but now it is and
so we want that right enshrined at the
United Nation